I think one of the interesting things to
observe is in the past couple years
since covid really a lot of people and
this I don't want to tell Tales of my
husband but my husband is included in
this category didn't believe that some
of this radical gender ideology was in
their local public school right like you
believed that it was in California you
might have believed it was in New York
you believed in an isolated incident
that you read on the news here or there
but you didn't believe that it was
everywhere that it could be in your own
neighborhood in front of your own child
and I think parents have really been
awakened to the fact that this this
capture of our education system is
complete this capture of our of our
education institution is total and that
your child will not be able to avoid it
you can't opt them out of social
emotional learning it's too it's too
integrated into into everything about
schools and social emotional learning a
lot of parents know what this is and
they find it to be questionable I talk
about this in my book because social
emotional learning is another name for
the critical Consciousness that at Paulo
Fieri the Brazilian Marxist wanted every
child to be brainwashed with it is it's
disguised as oh this is how we teach
children values this is how we teach
them morals this is how we teach them to
behave in in a manner that reflects
right and wrong but we should all be
asking well what is your definition of
right and wrong what is your definition
of a value
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of the Liz wheeler show as well
as the author of the new book hide your
children exposing the marxists behind
the attack on America's kids Liz wheeler
welcome back to the Reuben report
hi Dave thanks for having me
Liz I think if I'm not mistaken this is
your first solo appearance on the Reuben
report you've been on like a thousand
panel shows but is this our first
one-on-one
it is it is it it doesn't seem like the
first time because I'm so often on your
Friday show but yes this is this is
basically what it's like when you and I
hang out yeah
we shall see we shall see a lot of
pressure sister
um all right just real briefly for the
most of my audience of course knows you
but for the for the people that do not
know you you want to give a a minute
recap of who Liz wheeler is and why it
is that she's trying to save our kids
from the marxists
yes indeed I'm Liz wheeler I host the
Liz wheeler show you can subscribe on
Apple podcasts or wherever you watch or
wherever you watch or listen to your
pods I'm a political commentator I'm yes
thank you thank you maybe not YouTube
maybe head over to rumble if you value
Free Speech because we talk about a lot
of topics that are not allowed on
YouTube but what I'm most dedicated to
I'm a mom I'm dedicated to preserving my
this country this great country of ours
for my family for my two and a half year
old daughter I see what's happening
before our very eyes I see the capture
of our institutions I see the
degradation of the fabric of ordered
society and I don't want that for my
daughter the the best part of this
country is it gives us the opportunity
to live virtuously to worship the god
that we want to say what we want to live
our lives according to the tenets of our
viewpoints and if we if we don't stop
the assault against those things then
we're not going to have the country that
we have so we talk about everything from
covid to transgenderism to election
Integrity to the administrative State
really pushing aside The Establishment
republicanism that has actually led us
to where we are and taking a more based
View of reality in trying to solve the
crisis that we're facing when did you
realize the level of the craziness that
we were fighting meaning something that
was beyond just oh we're arguing about
tax breaks and we're arguing about you
know little this and that issues but
sort of the big cultural stuff that of
course leads to all the stuff related to
kids yeah that's a good question I'd
like to think and then maybe this is too
flattering it's too self-flattering I'd
like to think I've been based for a long
time because the way that I got into
politics and got into Political
commentary was kind of by accident I in
late high school I was diagnosed with a
serious autoimmune disease and I spent a
lot of time uh well being sick with that
and recovering from that and during that
period of time you know when you're sick
you're kind of bored there's not a lot
that you can do physically so I started
reading a lot of books and getting
involved this was like at the very
beginning of political Twitter getting
involved in political discussions on
Twitter just that was that was one of my
interests I liked sort of the adrenaline
that went with politics but I also at
the same time given what I was dealing
with personally came to a realization
that these so-called institutions that
we trust the quote unquote experts
aren't always dedicated to being an
expert in their field they're not always
dedicated to science for example there
was no pharmaceutical solution to the
autoimmune disease that you know I still
manage I still deal with and what does
big Pharma do they just kind of brush
you to the side they aren't interested
in saying well maybe if you manage your
diet differently maybe if there's some
kind of natural supplements or something
that you can do alternatively that this
would help you have more chance of
living a normal life they don't give any
of that advice they're only interested
in profiteering off of people's problems
so I think that I was for better for
worse red pilled at a relatively early
age because I saw that the only reason
that I was able to actually pursue those
alternative means to health was because
my dad is a small business owner and he
used the money that he saved to pay out
of pocket for these alternative
treatments whereas if we were in a
socialist nation and he was free to
enjoy the fruits of his labor if we had
a socialized Health Care system I
wouldn't have been able to do that so I
think I was red pilled and kind of
cynical about institutions from the
beginning and then once you once you
realize that that's the case in in one
institution you see it happening in the
other institutions as well
and isn't that ironic because some of
the positions you were talking about
being you know sort of leery of say big
Pharma uh those would have been thought
of as Lefty positions say 15 years ago
and now especially since covet that has
just completely flipped on us
it's so funny because for the majority
of my adult life I'm 34 and for the
majority of my adult life I've lived in
two different worlds I live in the I
would say very conservative World in
politics and then I live with a bunch of
I live in a world uh not literally not
like a commune but with a bunch of
crunchy leftists who also go to the
chiropractor and also try to eat
plant-based and these people are
generally like really woo-woo hippy
dippy crunchy people and they're
leftists in their politics for whatever
reason
um but now it is funny it's it's it's
even like questioning things like
questioning vaccines that was always a
leftist position until the code vaccine
and now the right has adopted that it's
it's funny to be in my position where
I've always been on the line of
conservative politics but leftist if you
will Health views because now it's like
well yes join the club
right you were also much like me you
were in Cali for covid you fled
California you did not make it to the
free state of Florida you went elsewhere
but you want to talk about how you were
based in Cali during a time of covid
yes yes I will and by the way for
everyone watching and listening to this
this is an ongoing this is bullying from
Dave to get me to come to Florida which
I appreciate I appreciate although the
humidity might be a little high I love
California here's the thing I don't I
don't hate California with this this
visceral this visceral rage that a lot
of people feel towards I think
California's Paradise I think there's a
reason that historically the golden
state was the land of opportunity this
is where you would go California to seek
your fortune really to find the American
dream and it actually breaks my heart to
see what's happening in California
because California is still Paradise in
a sense it's beautiful there's so many
resources it's it's like nowhere else in
the United States my heart is in
California and it really is just
crushing to see what leftist politics do
to a land that is so beautiful and so
prosperous and somewhere that that it
used to be everyone desired to move to
but with the open border and with Gavin
Newsom at the home with his technocratic
dictatorship in California with his
dedication to quote unquote climate
change with cracking down on Free Speech
they have a law right now that they're
trying to pass it to Bill I suppose that
they're trying to pass into law that
would actually Define parents who
declined to put their children on a
gender affirming quote-unquote gender
affirming model as child abusers you
can't raise a family in a in a climate
like that that you risk losing your
child the thing around which your entire
life revolves I mean we are fighting in
politics Dave you and I because we want
what's best for our children it's not
even about us we're adults we're halfway
through our lives already this is about
what's best for our families and you
can't raise a family in that
circumstance you have to leave and it
makes me really sad because I didn't
want to leave
it's so interesting because for me you
know as a relatively new father like
when that thing was being passed in Cali
which passed the legislature by the way
right I mean it's passed already now
it's about divorced families but they're
going to expand it obviously I I kept
saying on the show it's like you must
leave now if you're a parent because
you're sending your kids to schools
where they will be brainwashed into this
stuff and you don't want to be there
that day when they come knocking at your
door and you know we're calling uh your
your daughter a boy's name and if you
don't accept it we're taking the kid but
it's real
yeah it's it's real and this is what I
write in my book I mean the left is
actually waging a deliberate and
Relentless assault on our children this
is not hyperbole this is not bombastic
this has been going on for the last
century for a century the Left has
attempted to re-engineer society they've
actually captured and co-opted four of
the five foundational cultural
institutions in our nation the media and
religion and education and law and
they've just about destroyed the family
as well there's one element that is
remaining of the family and that is
children and the left now has their
sights set on our children and meanwhile
while all of this was happening what
were conservatives doing we were
complacent we were we were blind to this
we were blithely unaware as this was
happening and now we face what we're
facing we Face a a literal assault on
our children and so in the book I name
the names of the people behind not only
the capture of these institutions but
behind the attack on America's kids if
we don't acknowledge the reality of the
political enemy that we're facing we'll
lose we will not win and it's it's not
just a matter of fighting for the sake
of children's individual Souls if the
left successfully captures children our
nation is done
so one thing that I thought was
interesting in terms of the title is
that you said marxists you didn't say
walksters you didn't say Communists or
socialists you said Marxist I wonder
what was your thinking on that do you
want to Define it clearly and maybe
contrast it to some of those other terms
because everyone's sort of using them
interchangeably these days
it is and it's actually interesting
because when I started writing this book
I wasn't looking for Marxist it wasn't a
fishing Expedition I I acknowledged what
almost every person in our country has
acknowledged that there is this
sustained assault on our children from
all of these different angles and I
thought why why now why in this
coordinated way and it turns out the
answer to that question isn't a why it's
a who who is behind this and why are
they doing that and it turned out that
there was a pattern of ideology behind
each of these assaults so for example
what I found is there is a a Marxist by
the name of Antonio gromsey who
essentially brought back from the dead
original Marxism he he he revived it and
turned it into 21st century Marxism and
he twisted it from purely economic
Marxism like oh the working class is
going to revolt against the ruling class
he turned it into well wait a second the
working class isn't going to revolt
again against the ruling class if they
rely on the cultural institutions of the
working class so we said before we stage
an economic Revolution we have to Stage
a cultural revolution we have to go
after these five major foundational
civil institutions the media education
religion the law and the family and what
we are seeing now it's so interesting
Dave what we're seeing right now is not
new it's not a new idea it's not a new
ideology it's not a new enemy it's
actually 100 sometimes hundreds of years
old it's just been repurposed for this
moment it's why I say if we don't
acknowledge what we're facing we're not
going to fight well against it but once
you see who's behind the assault on each
of these institutions
I mean you can you can certainly put a
stop to it because you can simply you
can simply thwart their strategy which
these old marxists lay out maybe even
more clearly than the new leftists do
today
do you make any meaningful distinction
between some of those terms woke Marxist
communist socialist at this point like
does it matter to delineate that any any
further
yeah it does matter so the word woke
there were a month or two ago there was
a debate uh it was it crossed over from
conservative media to to liberal media
about what the word woke means what
what's the definition of the word woke
what is what does this mean and it's a
great question it's an answer it's a
question we should all be asking so I
actually traced can I do mine can I do
mine in two sentences and you tell me if
I'm doing it all right
because everybody was asking can I do
mine lay it on me it's it's believing in
equity over equality with a dash of
racism and a little gender confusion
how's that
that's exactly how it's manifested and
applied the ideology underneath it can
be traced directly to a Brazilian
Marxist named Paulo frieri Paulo frieri
applied this idea to the education
system in Brazil he actually
experimented on peasants in Brazil he
ran these like 45 day experiments on
peasants teaching them only leftist
things in school so that they would then
go out and vote for leftist politicians
and he said that teaching knowledge in
school was oppressive he said knowledge
there's there's no such thing as
knowledge there's no such thing as truth
or objective reality it's just he said
he defined uh knowledge and fact as just
the prevailing political ideology right
he said children instead of being taught
knowledge should be taught critical
Consciousness which is a way of thinking
about the world now critical
Consciousness is just a euphemism for
teaching children to view everything
through the lens of Marxism that's what
wokeness is wokeness is just a
rebranding of freery's critical
Consciousness so if you look at wokeness
in our country whether it's corporations
whether it's in the classroom whether
it's Dei whether it's gender ideology
it's all free areas critical
Consciousness it's training this this
young generation of American children to
view everything through the Marxist lens
of oppressor versus oppressed that the
oppressed have to revolt against the
oppressors overthrow the Civil
institutions for what purpose for the
purpose that marxists have laid out from
the very beginning to overthrow Western
Civilization
as evil as you think the ideology
obviously is are you ever impressed with
their ability to have had it spread and
how quickly it's destroyed so much and
and also how no matter what happens it
always causes them to double down so you
know for example if we reverse systemic
racism through the Supreme Court getting
rid of affirmative action somehow now
that actually is proof to them that the
courts are corrupt thus more fuel for
their fire
listen you know what impresses me and
what I I actually paused when I was
writing this book because it like hit me
as a revelation it impresses me that the
Democratic party today always operates
as a cohesive unit like they never have
any significant dissenters like it's
they always are Marching In lockstep and
you compare that to republicans in
Congress or in the Senate and
Republicans seem kind of haphazard
they're not always cohesive they can't
always like move as a unit and sometimes
conservatives are like oh that's because
we allow independent thinkers in the
Republican party that's not actually why
Republicans don't operate in lockstep
it's because Democrats are committed to
their ideology they know what their
ultimate goal is and they know the tools
that they're using to achieve their
ultimate goal but Republicans have lost
sight of what our ultimate goal is if
you ask any Republican in elected office
any Republican commentator a republican
voter what what is the ultimate
um goal of our society what do we hope
to achieve with our society most of them
can't answer what that is they can't
answer well is freedom the means to
something greater or is freedom the
ultimate end because those two things
are radically different and radically
change what our governing philosophy is
at the state level in the federal level
and if we don't as Republicans have a
cohesive definition of what we want for
our society then of course we're not
going to agree on how we achieve that
and then we're just going to be a
chaotic party like we are and what
happens when we have a chaotic party it
leads us to the cultural crisis that
we're in right now
yeah do you sense some of that shifting
with the Republicans at all
I sense a new and I find delightful
tension in the Republican party where
some people are waking up to the fact
that the Old Guard of republicanism is
as effective I think a lot of people
don't know why the Old Guard isn't
effective we oftentimes
um ascribe it to just being corrupt and
don't get me wrong there's plenty of
corruption in politics even on the
Republican side but it's not just
corruption it is the lack of ability to
Define that the goal of a society should
be human flourishing we want human
beings to flourish that's what we want
from a society that's the goal of the
United States of America our experiment
in Liberty the goal is human flourishing
maybe we Define human flourishing
differently than the left does which
just begets another conversation how are
we going to Define what's the base level
here the the reality that we will all
agree on to build our society off of
towards something towards what what are
we going to order it for what what's the
purpose of Liberty and I'll give you a
concrete example here so David French we
all know him he was at the National
Review he's now in the New York Times he
now writes for the New York Times he
made an argument once that drag queen
story hours where grown men dressing as
sexualized stereotypical versions of of
women gyrate in front of children in
scanty outfits it's horrendous he once
made the argument that that was one of
the blessings of liberty guaranteed in
our Constitution and I actually think
that this is a perfect example of a
disordered view on whether Liberty
should be the means to something greater
or whether Liberty is the end in and of
itself if you define Liberty as the
ultimate goal then yes David French is
correct because just the Liberty to do
something like that even if you and I
find it to be horrendous would be moral
because they have the Liberty to do that
but we understand everyone understands
that this is not a moral thing this is
an abjectly immoral thing for men to act
in that sexual manner around children
it's horrendous we all know this at a
gut level of visceral level which should
bring us to the question okay well if
Liberty is not the ultimate end then
what is the ultimate end is Liberty but
the means to something greater and if so
we should pass laws and order our
society from the local state and federal
level are institutions such as the
education system and our religious
institutions towards that which Liberty
allows us to achieve
so would you say that our institutions
can actually be reverted back to
something more sane or can change at all
or do you think they all need to be
blown up
or maybe it's Case by case depending on
religious institution versus
governmental
Etc yeah yeah
both I mean they're obvious there are
obvious examples of Institutions that
should just be raised and rebuilt in
some form like the FBI or you know the
Department of Justice or the public
school system that have just been
captured Beyond recognizable uh beyond
what is recognizable they've been
completely hijacked and weaponized and
are being used for evil and they should
be abolished they should they should we
should get rid of them and we can then
discuss what comes next but we can
recapture our institutions it's possible
um it's not easy and I don't want to be
one of those Republicans that says oh
you know what if you just pray a lot or
if you just make good decisions in your
personal life that will have a
trickle-down effect to politics I'm not
degrading either of those things I I'm a
devout Christian I pray every day I try
to order my personal life and my family
life towards what I think is good and
right and beautiful and just but that's
not enough conservatives have fallen for
this idea that government in and of
itself is bad and therefore any use of
of government is somehow tinged with
um with with stigma right that only
liberals use government to achieve their
ends this is not true this is not how
our constitution was set up we actually
have a responsibility and a duty to use
government to properly order our society
towards I would argue that that the that
freedom is a means to Justice we should
use our government to order our society
towards True Justice in fact I don't
believe in neutrality so I don't believe
that if we withdraw from government
because we we don't want the stigma of
using government to achieve our ends I
don't believe that we can keep a neutral
playing field either the left is going
to occupy it or we're going to occupy it
right now the left is uh but we can
there's nothing holding us back except
ourselves
would you say the best current example
of that is what's gone on with Disney
over the past year where DeSantis
actively decided to fight the culture
war and then suddenly Republicans like
Mike Pence like Chris Christie like
Nikki Haley all were suddenly saying
this isn't what we use government for
and it's like if that's not what you use
government for to get rid of crony
capitalism to save our children etc etc
then I don't know then I guess you're
all anarchists more than uh let's say
Republicans or conservatives I guess
would be your point
yes that's a perfect example that's a
perfect example DeSantis Governor
DeSantis used his just power as Governor
to order Society to hold accountable an
organization that had special privileges
from the government when it benefited
the people of the state and revoking
those special privileges when that
entity no longer benefited the state he
had an absolute right to do that it's
not even controversial another good
example is the the bills in States
across the country some of them are laws
they're they're basically in litigation
right now on whether states can prohibit
transgender surgeries for minors you
have a lot of Republican can't even
candidates for president I think Chris
Christie and ASA Hutchinson both said
you know that's not the that's not the
in in that's not the role of the
government to ban that that should be a
parent's decision and my response to
that is you don't you don't understand
reality here we already use government
to prohibit parents from abusing their
children right you're not allowed to
physically or verbally uh abuse your
child as as that's that's correct that's
exactly what the government should do is
is prevent that type of abuse and we use
it culturally and societally too a child
for example is not allowed to go in
under the floor of a casino why because
as a society we agree that that is not a
moral thing a proper thing for a child
to be doing a child's not allowed to go
into an establishment that primarily
serves alcohol we already use the
government to not to supersede parental
rights I'm all about parental rights but
to protect children from abuse to
protect children from abject immorality
if it is not the role of the government
to protect these young children from
exploitation from from Pharmaceuticals
and cross-sex hormones and surgery that
will ruin their bodies for life then my
goodness what is the purpose of
government like why do we even bother
how much of the the stuff related to
kids as you mentioned you have a two and
a half year old you've you've given us a
lot of sage wisdom as as new fathers
over here but being a new mother how
much of that affected how clearly
passionately you feel about all of this
and and what do you think you'll do
going forward in terms of schooling and
and all of that because these are
decisions I'm gonna have to make as well
soon enough
yeah definitely and just for everyone
watching you should know that the
majority of our texting threads are like
crunchy parenting advice being sent back
and forth
um it's a constant no it's it's already
impacted my decisions about how how my
husband and I have have begun to raise
our two and a half year old you know we
don't defer to The Experts you know that
I'm kind of anti-pediatrician because I
don't trust pediatricians who are
beholden to the American Academy of
Pediatrics if they don't operate by the
standards of care that the American
Academy of Pediatrics lays out then they
can be held legally accountable or
they're liable legally and so they don't
give their best judgment they just say
what the AAP says the AAP Stan like
recommends transgender surgeries for
kids and talks about Dei and that's not
even that's not even taking into
consideration the big Pharma corruption
with this 74 vaccine schedule for
children and the the questionable
efficacy and safety of That vaccine and
the fact that you're not allowed as a
parent to question it I mean it's
already in you're not even allowed to
question the schedule right I mean it's
one thing to question the vaccine they
don't even want you questioning the
schedule I had RFK Jr on last week
that's what we were discussing
yeah I had to fire my first pediatrician
that I that I had for my daughter
because he was just giving me the
business about uh questioning or spacing
or doing anything that differed just
slightly from the CDC and the aap's
recommended schedule and I'm like I'm
not about this like I'm I'm the parent
here I don't want to co-parent with the
government I don't want to co-parent
with a corrupted institution going
forward I mean we're planning she's only
two and a half so she has a few years
but we're planning to homeschool there's
no way that I'm going to send my child
to a public school no wait in this world
I think one of the interesting things to
observe is in the past couple years
since covid really a lot of people and
this I don't want to tell Tales of my
husband but my husband is included in
this category didn't believe that some
of this radical gender ideology was in
their local public school right like you
believed that it was in California you
might have believed it was in New York
you believed in an isolated incident
that you read on the news here or there
but you didn't believe that it was
everywhere that it could be in your own
neighborhood in front of your own child
and I think parents have really been
awakened to the fact that they this this
capture of our education system is
complete this capture of our of our
education institution is total and that
your child will not be able to avoid it
you can't opt them out of social
emotional learning it's too it's too
integrated into into everything about
schools and social emotional learning a
lot of parents know what this is and
they find it to be questionable I talk
about this in my book because social
emotional learning is another name for
the critical Consciousness that Paulo
Fieri the Brazilian Marxist wanted every
child to be brainwashed with it is it's
disguised as oh this is how we teach
children values this is how we teach
them morals this is how we teach them to
behave in in a manner that reflects
right and wrong but we should all be
asking well what is your definition of
right and wrong what is your definition
of a value and if you dig into that
social emotional learning which is in
every Public School most private schools
too in our country is it's it's just
Marxism it is a Marxist worldview it's
critical Consciousness it's wokeness
whatever term you want to use to
describe it and I cannot expose my child
to that so I'm sitting here waiting for
the Hillsdale homeschool curriculum to
draw the intent any anybody at Hillsdale
who's listening
I can't say too much but I know that a
couple people in Florida are working on
a couple solutions to this stuff uh that
might work out because uh you know
you've got a two and a half year old so
there's a little time to play with there
um I think a lot of people are sort of
on board this idea that the secular
institutions have failed but maybe
they're not quite realizing how badly
the religious institutions have also
failed and I would say that probably
goes across virtually all of the
religious institutions in the country
regardless of denomination can you talk
about that a little bit
yeah it's quite sad I'm a devout
Catholic I'm a practicing Christian and
it was quite sad doing the research for
this part of my book because I looked at
some of the surveys about not just
religious participation like attendance
of church that's obviously down and it's
been trending down for a long time but
if you look at what people actually
believe there's only only three out of
ten Young Americans This is Gen Z and
Millennials if Millennials can still be
turned termed Young And as a millennial
I still claim that term
um only three out of ten believe in the
god of the Bible that means that the
overwhelming majority of of young people
in America don't believe in in anything
anything greater and anything bigger in
God in that aspect of reality and it
explains somewhat why there's so much
confusion about terms like justice and
right and wrong and morality and empathy
and love and compassion and tolerance
because if you don't have some kind of
fundamental belief then your everything
emanates out of that right like even in
our society right now we have laws
against homicide we have laws against
assaults we have laws against rape why
do we have these laws why do we have
them why why are these laws different
for human beings than they are for dogs
or horses because at the base level
whether you're a practicing religious
person or not are country's Foundation
acknowledges that human beings are made
in the image and likeness of God and as
such should be treated with dignity we
recognize at our constitution recognizes
the definition of what Justice is so not
to get too nerdy and historical here but
if if freedom is not the ultimate end if
freedom is the means to something
greater we should ask the question well
what is this something greater what is
it well our founding fathers that the
framers of our constitutions actually
defined what it is that our our society
should be ordered to and what it is is
Justice James Madison said in Federalist
51 that the definition of Liberty is
justice but what is Justice the framers
of our constitution Define that along
judeo terms that the definition of
justice was God's original Justice again
you don't have to be a practicing
religious person this is not a theocracy
but there is a necessity for some kind
of agreement on what these words mean or
else you're going to beget chaos and I
don't need to describe for everyone that
we are currently living in this chaos
right so I think most people watching
this agree with that for sure what would
you say has to happen to the
institutions I mean what do you for the
church for example since that's that's
your denomination I mean what do you
think actually has to happen
well I think the church the the Catholic
church I'll speak to personally because
I'm a practicing Catholic the Catholic
church has been extremely lacks in their
catechesis uh which means the teaching
of the faith to the faithful they have
not explained and defended the tenants
of the faith and when you uh when you
don't uh have a good grasp of what you
believe and why you believe it you are
very vulnerable to that that that which
you think you believe being Twisted by
someone else so for example we're told
by AOC that the green New Deal is
environmental justice we're told by
Planned Parenthood that abortion is
reproductive Justice if you don't have a
good understanding about what Justice
Means uh based on your your religious
belief then you're going to be very
vulnerable to falling for falling for
people that are lying to you people that
are false prophets so first of all the
church needs to be very clear about
their responsibility and their duty to
catechize their faithful if we did this
in a better way if we did this in a more
effective way then we would have more
cultural Warriors like you and I who
were unafraid to stand up against the
marxists assaulting our institutions the
church actually and I know this is
getting really nerdy but this is the
part of my book that might be my
favorite part the Catholic Church as an
institution what has been one of the
strongest
um bulwarks against communism and
Marxism and socialism in the modern
world the popes especially like around
the time of Marx and angles when they
were writing the Communist Manifesto
around the time of the Soviet Union it
was Catholic Popes who were saying
listen communism is satanic communism is
this is not just a political battle not
just a secular battle not just an
economic battle this is a battle of good
versus evil that communism comes from
the devil and that no Christian should
or can be both a Christian and a
communist Marxist or socialist they have
fought at the institutional level from
the beginning of this from the beginning
of Communism and Marxism against it but
recently they've lost their way recently
they've become a little less based and a
little more squishy not doctrinally but
in their Communication in their
um and and their willingness to fight
back so I of course I mean you know me I
I have strong opinions I'm not afraid of
I guess confrontation I don't want to
think of myself as a confrontational
person but it's necessary sometimes to
challenge what is wrong even if it's
uncomfortable and I feel like this is
true for Evangelical churches and
Protestant churches as well as the
Catholic Church they've forgotten that
sometimes love is you know Jesus
flipping tables it's not always let me
just scratch your back and Pat your head
and tell you that you're pretty and if
we get back to the true definition of
love and compassion and Justice then
it's going to equip a whole generation
of people to fight back against
essentially the Antichrist in in in the
Antichrist of communism
how worried are you that the machines
that AI the algorithms big Tech
that they will put their foot on the
scale they obviously haven't already but
if we were just having an ideological
battle Marxism versus say capitalism or
Freedom you know individualism versus
collectivism if we were just battling
that out
I think we win I think the human Spirit
wins and all that but now on that scale
also comes AI also comes manipulated
information also comes uh search engines
that will tell you the reverse of the
truth when you search certain things
that makes this battle much more
difficult
it does it does so AI I think a lot of a
lot of people mistake ai ai is not like
an autonomous entity it's not like a
sentient being AI is an algorithm it's a
piece of code that was written by
somebody and that somebody or somebody's
are very politically biased people who
have an agenda all you have to do is go
into chat gbt I actually did this this
weekend this past weekend I spoke the
young America's Foundation conference
and I beforehand I asked chat GPT to
write me a poem on the dangers of the
transgender ideology and Todd gbd told
me that it was discriminatory and
hateful and that they couldn't do it so
then I asked chat DBT to write me a poem
about the dangers of the gender binary
and it did write a poem about the
dangers of the gender binary so you can
see the obvious bias inherent to these
systems and the biggest danger of them
all is manipulation it's manipulating
people it's it's disguising the truth
and instead redefining words so that
people accidentally or unknowingly fall
for your idea geology meaning the
Marxist ideology
um on I agree with you on a Level
Playing Field capitalism would defeat
communism every time but that's why the
marxists are targeting our children
because they know if they wait till
they're adults and they allow them to
experience reality no one's ever going
to choose to be a communist but if they
can indoctrinate them if they can if
they can erase or twist and warp pollute
the natural law that exists within all
of us as our conscience as our reason
then they will be able to convince these
people these young children who in 10
years won't be children anymore to be
marxists to be Communists that's why
they're attacking our kids
so all that being said are you hopeful
that we can actually turn this thing
around I mean a whole bunch of us can
try to Red Pill people we can try to you
know get some more based people out
there and sensible people and all that
but it does seem like we we still lose a
lot of the mini battles we win little
ones like Disney or maybe that's a big
one but but overall the tendency
especially if you look at the polling of
young people thinking socialism is cool
like it does seem to be going the wrong
way
well listen I wouldn't be sitting here
if I thought it was a losing battle
that'd be too depressing I wouldn't
fight this battle if I thought it was
already lost so my my presence in this
in this battlefield uh is an indication
that I think that we can that we can win
you have to remember that this is not
something that happened overnight it's
not something that happened since Obama
took office or since Biden took office
or you know during the Trump years this
is this is uh an assault on our
institutions that's been going on for
almost a century a century 100 years
conservatives didn't recognize it we
were so uh drunk with our own prosperity
in our nation that we just sat by and
didn't recognize the spiritual battle
good versus evil that was raging around
us as these marxists went into our
education systems first you know ivy
league teachers colleges and
disseminated this poison into all of all
of these institutions I mean in in into
even the administrative state right Dr
fauci being like you listen to me I'm an
expert that's he's acting as a technique
I am the size
I am the science and you shouldn't
criticize it I worry if I'm criticized
fauci says but what he's doing is he's
he's acting as a technocrat we use that
term but what we should do when we say
that term is we shouldn't just say oh
yeah he's a technocrat that's an insult
that's a bad thing is we should say what
is a technocrat what is technocracy it's
ruled by the experts but I traced this
back actually in my book to the the
origin of technocracy and the origin of
technocracy one of the one of the
founders of technocracy was a Russian
scientist who admitted in his writings
that technocracy is nothing but a
stepping stone from capitalism to
Communism it's how you trick people in a
capitalist Society to transform
themselves into a communist Society so
yes we can undo this this first step to
undoing it is recognizing and
acknowledging the reality of the
political enemy we Face understanding
all of this ideology and the people
behind it and the second part is not
quite as easy I'm not going to pretend
to be one of those Republicans that it's
just like Paul Ryan if we get our fiscal
house in order everything will follow or
if you just mind your own business in
your own house everything will it'll be
a downstream effect no we have to be
comfortable as a Republican party using
the government to ban Dei to ban ESG to
ban transgender surgeries for children
we have to abolish the administrative
State we have to actively once we play
defense in that way we have to play
offense we have to mandate that children
in public schools are taught about the
horrors of Communism that they are that
they are taught the science of of of sex
and I'm not talking about sex like
reproduction I'm talking about I don't
want to use the word gender because it's
been co-opted but biological reality and
DNA yeah the biological reality of male
and female we have to be able and
willing and understand that this is our
heritage our constitutional Heritage is
a Heritage of ordered Liberty not this
um not this absolute Liberty it's a I
don't even want to call it
libertarianism because it kind of is but
it's a little bit further than Liberty
where it's ultimately just going to turn
into social Anarchy if we Embrace that
even if it sounds cool on its surface we
have to be cohesive as a Republican
party and use government where we have
the just authority to do so it's not
easy but it can be done
you're basically saying by day three in
burning man it's time to uh you know go
home I think something like that
um yeah yeah I what I wrote in my book
is I was like listen the first half of
this book can be somewhat depressing not
that you should come away from it
depressed but like it's heavy stuff to
realize exactly how the left this huge
plot behind I mean we talk often about
George Soros and how he's behind so many
things I don't talk about Soros as much
in this book because some of the
um institutions and people behind the
attack on our nation's kids and on our
institutions take the form of these
shadowy complicatedly named uh groups
and and institutions but what they're
propagating is the ideology of Marxism
so what I want people to come away with
after they read this book is a thorough
understanding of the ideology so that
you can look at social emotional
learning you can look at teaching for
social justice you can look at
technocracy and you can say wait a
second I recognize that I recognize the
elements of Marxism inherent to that and
it gives me strength and the capacity to
uh to utterly reject it so the first
half may be heavy but the second half
like listen you are going to come out
swinging after you put this book down
because it is my editor actually told me
that the last chapter was intimidating
for a president of the United States let
alone a flustern parent and I was like
thank you I take that as a compliment
that's what the Republican party needs
we don't need soft establishment
leadership we need someone that's like
it's not going to be easy but if you
actually want to win here's a blueprint
for how to do it
Liz as I always say to you but how do
you really feel if I could only figure
it out if you could just be a little
clearer in your language and tell me how
you really feel we are going to link to
the book down below it was a pleasure to
see you my friend and I will uh text you
some children questions after this
thank you Dave I really appreciate it
everyone just go to Amazon or wherever
you want to buy your books if you hate
Jeff Bezos and make sure you subscribe
Apple podcasts write down below thanks
Dave she's a podcast Pro all right
thanks Liz if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell